nothing
moving on now and the son of libya's
former leader muammar gaddafi has
registered as a candidate for december's
presidential elections saif al-islam
gaddafi said he wants to restore unity
after a decade of conflict since his
father's downfall the 49 year old is
wanted by the international criminal
court for war crimes ibrahim freihart is
an associate professor of conflict
resolution at the doha institute and
joins us live now thanks for joining us
uh ibrahim first of all this is a man
that was supposed to be executed at one
point and now he's registering as a
presidential candidate it certainly is a
significant turnaround will he have any
support
well he definitely benefited from the
chaos uh the security uh situation
that's in disarray in libya and that uh
ended up actually in uh releasing him in
2017
from prison though he had uh he received
a death sentence
in 2015 and he is still wanted by the
international criminal court now whether
he has support he does actually have
some support not a lot he has some
support among the former regime
loyalists
and also he has some support within some
certain tribal forces
they're not much uh
it's not a strong support they are in
places like uh benny waleed and tarhona
and and some other tribal forces
i don't think he has any chance of
winning this election i don't think he
uh he himself thinks that he has a
chance but for him i think this is a
political message that he is trying to
send that he is becoming uh again back
to the political scene and part of the
game and also that he can run for the
elections and he
he
is
ignoring the international criminal
court's uh
uh request for
for him to be handed over to the to the
icc so that's i think the political
message is what we're seeing behind it
and uh he is doing it uh now
as we see
yeah that was my next question ibrahim
given he's wanted for crimes against
humanity is is gaddafi even eligible to
run
well there is uh again as i said there
is a political uh chaos in libya now uh
there are no laws there are no rules
that are governing this uh whether this
elections or any other things as we know
libya is uh sharply and
sharply divided
polarized unfortunately among the
different political forces and there are
dozens of different political forces so
legality and law and uh
it's not the major driving force uh
that's regulating these elections or any
other things
because it depends where you know
what area are we talking about
uh we know that it's deeply divided
between east and west but we we are
seeing syphilis
actually is running from the south from
sabha so it's completely outside
this
area within the east and west equation
so he's coming with uh with a different
uh from a different area but for the icc
i think the request uh will still be
there because uh this is serious and
it's it's official
that they wanted uh
islamic gaddafi for war was against uh
uh
the the protesters in in libya during uh
his father's time so i think this
situation will continue and as in again
as i said
i don't think he has a serious chance
but it's the political message it's
what's driving his uh running for this
election
ibrahim how likely is it that these
elections on december 24th will even go
ahead given the disagreements over the
rules and the schedule of this poll
well in libya we learned that nothing
will happen until it happens and yes all
choices all scenarios are
out there on the table it depends on how
there are there there isn't one
decision-making process that uh is
taking place in in libya uh we know that
there are many uh that they're running
for this election uh
and several others that are running for
uh this election so
it all depends on how uh
how things go and whether these people
different political forces remain
committed uh to the political process so
it's a larger it's a part of a larger
issue
about the holy transition
issue the whole transitional process in
libya as long as there is a commitment
from the
domestic as well as the international
players in in libya then yes we can
expect that the elections will happen
but as we know again uh there are
different parties from within libya and
also internationally even the european
position is divided among like parties
like france and italy and several others
so uh i think it will be the outcome of
all these uh
of all this polarization within libya
whether we will see it for for sure
happening uh
in the proper time
well it's only a couple of weeks away so
we will watch and see thank you very
much ibrahim frahat in doha there